what's up y'all this is welcome party
where I sit down and chat with some of
my guys ENT the league today we got
Houston's own cam Whitmore happy to be
here thank you for having me yes sir
good to see you again all right first
let's start off with some fan questions
on the BR app today we got Justin
Rockets asking you're signed of Jordan
so start cut and bench ones fours or 11s
oh gosh
uh cut
ones um start fours and uh bench 11s
okay yeah okay what's your favorite
alltime shoe though alltime shoe is
fours and 12 depend what I'm wearing
okay I can't make a comment on that yeah
Famas fam let's do one more actually all
right now we got Alex asking one has to
go yeah DMV Edition Maryland Virginia
and
DC I say Maryland but shopping I would
go to DC okay yeah but Maryland for sure
that's Crib That's the home what about
Hoops though is the best hoopers in DMV
yeah DMV has the best hoopers for sure
not Kansas no no nobody out of
Kansas yeah no I don't know that's not a
lot of I mean we got good history but
it's like recently we I think we got
better
history our history is pretty
good I'll give it to you no I'm thinking
about it yeah probably everybody spread
out we got um Baltimore Maryland then we
got DC we got Virginia a little bit even
though it's different states but I mean
same same area same definitely more
hoopers of course yeah I'll give you
that one yeah but no let's take this all
the way back um back to pre-draft and
that process um Santa Barbara um quick
Turn Around from college um you know you
feel like you're playing at one point um
get out of March Madness and you're
already headed to you know work on your
craft to get to NBA so how was that
process for you I mean mine was a little
bit easier I wasn't in your position
position I mean you um very had a
successful college career so you went to
March Madness I didn't so mine kind of
um shifted very quick so uh after nit um
I kind of went home for a little bit had
to go back home then we went up to Santa
Barbara uh very beautiful atmosphere I
mean I would definitely live there when
it's all said and done but um yeah most
definitely I think I would definitely go
back there but um you know spending time
with you guys and uh I mean some people
I didn't even meet before um so I mean
it wasin definely a great atmosphere
just hang out with you guys you know on
the beach work out no doubt yeah no the
schedule is insane I I feel like for me
it was more of you know you're getting
your work done first and then you know
you have the rest of the day to kind of
have to yourself but you're about like
what like 100 feet really from the beach
I know I mean I'm I'm from Maryland so
I'm not really used to that you know
that beach yeah yeah the weather and
everything so uh yeah I think I think it
was definitely you know great for us
just to get out there for sure I think
it's too and the fact of you know when
you put everyone in One location like
that too it's competitive but in in the
most positive way because you know
you're all pushing each other um working
you know on basketball every single day
having fun too you know it's SP a little
bit you know games the one-onone games
the shooting TP competitions py was uh
you know helping us through of course
you know and that obviously it grows
your confidence even more um and really
just yeah push obviously to the to the
NBA and you know get you ready but um
what's that been you know your process
going actually through the NBA but the
confidence level building or you know
staying the same you know how's that
when you actually play against you know
these Hall of Famers LeBron everything
like that I mean it's it's different
like I've been you know waiting to since
I was a kid I mean me and you have been
watching NBA since uh growing up so I
mean um we've been seeing the you know
the LeBron the Kawhi Leonard Paul
George's um so I mean you know those
players that's you know those type of
people you know where we want to be at
and there you know their type of skill
set so I I think you know just why not
you know go at the best that's really
that's how I you know I view it yeah
like every every level is different the
game just you know moves a lot much
faster yeah no doubt you know I saw um
your little thing with LeBron you know
going going at him and I think this you
know it's great obviously cuz you hear
so many um different advice you know
different tips from these older guys
when you're coming in as a rookie you
know people are going to try to push you
around try to punk you and for sure um
you can't let him obviously no you
cannot butan see that was cool
definitely yeah I mean shoot staying
next to LeBron was definitely different
you can't can't be a fan on the court
but uh I mean before and after the game
like yeah you definitely can for sure
but for sure and then yeah you show that
emotion that confidence um and you
definitely see it on your team with
Dylan um show good emotion how's how's
being a teamate with him and see stuff
he does man being with DB is uh I mean
he's a he's a great that great teammate
um he just nothing you know wants the
best you know for his guys for his
teammates but I mean at the end of the
day he a competitor I mean that's
absolutely I mean the main thing like
what he's here to here to do like
guardar the best defender on every team
I mean he does you know pretty good job
of it but uh I mean he's he's not afraid
of nothing he's Fearless so I mean
that's that's one thing I'm I'm very
like high on with him for sure and I
mean stuff's going to be on social media
that's just how it's always going to be
of yeah things but the thing if you
actually watch the game it's the players
that actually you know want to lock up
guys like that that's the most important
thing he's different he's not really
like that on social media though yeah
he's not that's good and I mean along
with those trash talkers who who else on
the league you think or you come across
or you see that yeah goes in that genre
I would say uh who I've really played
against I would say I mean I just played
against uh Brandon Ingram he got he got
a little bit like something under his
breath he be he be talking not loud yeah
uh yeah I mean I'm still you know going
through the league but uh KD as he got
always you know something that's you
know that's how you know from the crib
so I mean you know Maryland people with
the MV people always uh you know just
got their chip on that shoulder and just
you know always taught yeah sweet and
going back to um you're talking about
vets and the importance of just a little
advice and stuff they give um I think
for me personally the biggest advice was
going actually through the g-league
experience yeah um and just listening
from guys like Pascal um that have gone
through there and succeeded you know
amazingly um what do you feel like your
experience cuz we both went through it
and um just did our jobs at the end of
the day but yeah what do you think like
has that helped you going through get
different advice from you know the Vets
or anything like that what you think uh
I would say um like it definitely just
helped me you know not not be a better
basketball player just like I'll say be
a man just like I mean even though it's
a job at the end of the day but like
just you know the quick turnarounds I
don't know how it was for you but like
it was just um like I was on a flight um
and they would just tell me I'm waking
up from a nap it would just tell me yeah
I'm going down or just like after
practice I think I'm you know going back
to my crib I'm about to go on a flight
like later that night so um I just think
you know just got just learn you know
handle your business like put your head
down just keep working but I mean my
think my G League experience was just
like uh you know somewhere I can just
you know be free and just work on my
game even though I have the green light
so um how was it for you I know you know
went down to the G League unexpectedly
same thing as me so I think yeah you
talking about you know different flights
and everything like that you it makes a
time fly for sure um you know my
experience was you're playing yeah I'm
with the Raptors and then it'll be maybe
an off day with the Raptors and the next
day you're thinking oh recovery day yeah
we play 11:00 a.m. game or 3 p.m. game
or um just yeah quick turnarounds but
you know it's been great and I think I
mean I kept talking about just advice
that I've got when I would play with
them is um you go with the open mind you
know a positive um feel for it and if
you make anything negative you know
that's that's what they look for you
know I feel like it was um what I tried
to keep in in in my mindset and know you
go down there and think any different
you play different than you would you
know with um your team it's
it's negative in the coach's mind so I
feel like you just go in there and play
really what got you drafted in the first
place I think is yeah I'm going to PVE
the way for you so facts I mean I mean
the G leag was definitely fun I mean I I
had a good time you know Rio Grande
Valley is definitely you should go visit
sometime too I got you yeah for sure but
that was some real stuff right there but
let's go a little more more on a better
topic I'm
of I got a good one actually a fan Matt
was asking that was a bad huh that was I
feel like we we were talking real stuff
for a minute so I need to lighten the
mood a little I guess I feel yeah all
right would you rather he word it a
little different would you rather tooth
Gems or
tattoos dang I got both
uh tattoos tattoos yeah tattoos I don't
know how's the two gim work you got to
explain that to me cuz I tooth gem um
don't know really like braces I mean
have had braces no yeah yeah so I mean
like you know get the tooth gem put on
the tooth you know make sure you line it
up a bit sh make sure you line it up a
bit make sure it's not crooked or
anything um has some you know special
glue some braces glue you just you know
leave it on there for about 30 seconds
she presses it you know really really
tight doesn't hurt at all um after that
she puts some like the you know that
blue light you know like whitens your
teeth M but it just makes it stick so
she puts that on there now that hurts a
little bit like it makes your little
your tooth ache a little bit you have it
you have it all right yeah I li see too
yeah but I mean your tooth aches a
little bit but after that I mean you're
good I have to you get multiple ones or
get a whole Grill sure too you can get
whatever you want I get one on every
tooth you could but might as well just
get a girl n just one let's start out
one I start out one too but good oh you
said tattoos though what's your favorite
one I got this one right here this is my
uh my first one it's my first tag Space
Jam type of tag cuz I mean I like to I
like to dunk I do like basketball so I
remember actually you got on Santa
Barber though right with the pre I did
yeah it was a yinyang symbol it's it's
up here but yeah it was yinyang symbol I
guess be sure that actually got you got
it it was a butterfly yeah I forgot yeah
yeah Santa barbar was you know I let my
uh mom know maybe a little too much
after the fact she knew she knew the
idea of it but I don't think she knew
the time frame of it so after Santa
Barbara you told her yeah I was like I
might get in a couple weeks She's Like H
I like the idea but maybe just wait see
had to keep my first one for my mom me
and my dad went I got one and then you
know she kind of spaz out on me a little
bit after but it's it's cool she forgive
me at the end of the day that's good
that's good but yeah actually Let's do
let's do another uh fan
question Alex asked how did it feel to
get your first NBA
start
um I would say uh it was different like
I mean it was guess the Boston Celtics
that's like the number one team in the
in the league so um definitely eye
opener and uh I'm definitely you know
grateful for the opportunity you know
with my other rookie am men Thompson so
uh I mean we didn't you know come out on
top but I mean it was it was a close
game yeah no definitely a a special
moment know for sure you know not a lot
of people can say yeah they've been in
the NBA not let alone you started the
NBA as a rookie so I wish we had more
Rockets fans at that game but I mean but
no definitely cool definitely cool um
let's take this even further back even
past the the pre-draft stuff um back to
high school you know we were both in the
McDonald's stuff might have been the
first the first time we met yeah that
was
yeah yeah it was we played against each
other um what you think of experience
with that cuz I know for me it
was it surprised me a little I mean
there's here and there Au stuff you
start getting interviews and stuff but
once you see the actual camera lights
the McDonald's and and a kind of w like
that is pretty crazy I say like that was
my like my first major like camp or like
you know showcase you know game but um
at first I didn't I didn't really think
I was gonna make it at first but I mean
I went to you know we went to Chicago um
that's fun like the Social Media stuff
like the you know the cameras all in
your face like yeah like all that was
different like we're high school and
kids I didn't really get that but uh
yeah I mean it's definitely you know
great great atmosphere great experience
with everybody else yeah for sure I
think a lot of people didn't see
actually and me going into it
was obviously you're going to play every
game yeah as hard as you can but it was
less of the actual McDonald's game I
feel like the most important part was
like the practices in between yeah and
the stuff people didn't see cuz that's
when like all the Scout Scouts was you
know all lined down like
from front Court to the back court I
mean it was yeah it was crazy I didn't I
didn't even know that was going to
happen anyway NBA PR GM watching high
schoolers that was my first kind of
taste of that and yeah yeah a lot of a
lot of pressure but I mean it makes you
yeah I mean that's you the only Kansas
one out for the McDonald's American me
and Mark
Mitchell he's from Kansas yeah K City
area yeah yeah about like two hours from
me but funny thing is all McDonald's all
Americans are like you know at the
league right now too so I mean how many
DMV were
there just me it was just me but we got
some underrated guys so we got some
under guys that's coming of course good
stuff but yeah know along with those um
type of games and awards um moved on
past the past the pre uh excuse me
pre-draft process um going into summer
um a lot of the time was getting into
Vegas um getting with your team and what
was your experience like your first time
meeting them really um it wasn't really
like a lot of the guys you would play
with but along with the organization
like you're meeting um staff members for
the first time you're mean really just
kind of thrown without practice really
and just playing in in the summer league
yeah uh I mean right after um the draft
uh I mean I went home for a little bit
but I mean went to Houston after I went
back home so I mean like the hospitality
there was like I mean great they welcom
I mean both rookies I mean just like I
mean it was just like no other home so I
mean coaching staff um at the time
summer league coaching staff um players
that's been there especially bar to our
you know being leaders and vets um young
leaders and vets you know just uh to
lead us you know to summer league but um
you had a couple good good practices um
at ufh you know just to get a feel and
get some chemistry going with some some
the G League guys and uh the um past
Rocket players first year guys so I mean
uh it was definitely a quick turnaround
I mean just whole like couple four
months out of college was you know a
quick turnaround so I mean uh it was
definitely definitely different how was
it for you it was cool as I talked about
I mean just meeting the people um I
think was important and putting you know
names to faces yeah all that stuff and I
mean obviously you dominated got the MVP
so thank you and know good with that but
um I feel like those games
um obviously they're going to you know
get you ready for the season but it's
yeah it's more of you know learning from
the coach and like learning from like
the team's um schemes and all that stuff
and yeah know how you're going to be
used you know in their and on their team
and on on the court and you know Finding
different positions I mean in my case
you know I'm going to be more of a
stress shooter so I'm just finding where
I need to be on the court
and um you know the court is so much
bigger so it's like how canot move
around it you you feel like it was
different from college or I would say it
was very much faster I mean like two up
and backs like I was I was tired already
but I mean it was uh I mean it was just
just preparation you know just keep
working at it m but I mean like like
yours definitely different you had to go
to Canada like that's like start I know
that was big like that's I mean shoot
yeah I've been in Kansas my whole life
so it was a different change um there's
no Tonto is just I don't know it's
different like you get there and it just
feels like there's little little things
that like don't feel American at all
yeah obviously but like you know what I
mean like gu just I get it the currency
yeah show me a good time I I ain't never
been to Canada before yeah sure yeah I'm
about to but I ain't never been I'll
show you around let me know when you get
there but here before we get to coming
up we got the allstar coming up in a
couple weeks but let's get another fan
question in here yeah um Daniel ask your
favorite F Food Spot in Houston favorite
food
spot I would say stick talk or uh it
this Mediterranean spot called Hala I
don't know how to pronounce it but it's
Hala something like that that's good
food yeah food is that Mediterranean
food okay different food that's Toronto
has crazy Foods just there diverse music
food everything that's one thing I I
love and there's different things you
can try all the time yeah what type of
music music they got like Drake and
stuff yeah they got Drake that's normal
yeah Drake uh they love their like afro
beats ree yeah um all the kind of Island
music type stuff which I love that's one
of my favorite typ music all right let's
see who's next crisp and clean what did
you think of Houston before you even
actually got there like here I guess I
mean I knew it was like you know warm
but I didn't I didn't think it was like
everything was spread out I didn't think
the food was that good uh I mean it's
probably the best best food I mean every
state but yeah I mean the people are
very nice very respectful loyal I mean
yeah the hospitality is great quick yeah
just really really great people here
that's good that's good all right next
one fan Keith
Jack which rocket Jersey is your
favorite that you worn or I guess in his
I'll say the one um the one with the uh
with the um the rocket the rocket ship
mhm the um the dun the dun shaut yeah
that's what it's called have you worn
that yet yeah yeah yeah you were all the
time right yeah it was the yeah the
white jersey with the um with the
astronaut that be that dunks yeah I'm
think of the um you know she got a
purple one no we don't get no the
history and like all time nah that much
just be us the little Raptor N I think
it was yeah it was y'all y'all yeah that
was y'all with the VIN Carter yeah all
right let's do one more before we get to
Allstar Ian asked what's it like playing
with Fred and Jaylen and how do you um
their still style dang play Styles
compliment
yours uh I mean Fred is a point gu so I
mean he's going to find you regardless I
mean if you play off Fred he's he's
going to give you the ball um and Jaylen
he's just I mean another scorer so I
mean I mean we definitely like the
chemistry off the court mixes in with
the chemistry on the court so I once you
have that I mean two to two together
like I mean for sure yeah showtime for
sure and we're definitely both athletes
so yeah it's good it's going to be fun
tomorrow I guess for sure I can't wait
yeah no a couple weeks we got allar
coming up yeah um for the NBA and you
know and that is obviously the dunk
contest you yourself have had some crazy
dunks in the past um this season
so U what's it like would you ever see
yourself being in a dunk contest for
sure I would I would defin we try it I
mean one day but uh not all people knows
what comes with that like I mean it's a
contest also you got to have some stuff
up your sleeve yeah but uh I'll
definitely um I would want to do it one
day but as of right now like I mean I'm
trying to get my feet wet on the NBA
floor right quick but for sure be cre
nothing against it yeah no of course
so who would be your four say say pick
four players all time don't to be right
now that would you put in a dunk contest
all time players yeah anyone oh Vince
Carter Dominique
Wilkins MJ
uh and I would have to put Sean km who's
winning Sean km he's winning it oh you
said he's winning who's winning it Vince
Carter yeah Vince Carter yeah shout out
to ronto don't act like you don't got
sneaky bounce too huh I said don't act
like you don't got sneaky bounce I got
the creative I got the lengthy bounce
you can definitely get in there the
sneaky bounce
good head on his shoulders yeah no yeah
in my case you know it' be a definitely
cool thing to yeah um Char for the
Three-Point Contest one day um the way I
play but um obviously like you said
earlier I think the most important thing
is you know getting your feet wet um
getting to this to your team and just
working as hard as you can every day and
just try to sit make a name for yourself
yeah for sure I mean obviously thear is
going to be a huge goal to go strive for
but yeah you know got to pay the way
first that's definitely the goal why not
for sure for sure well let's do one more
fan question and then we're going to get
to one more Allstar question one more
allar Adrian asked hey cam what's your
pregame ritual pregame ritual is uh I
usually I got the gun that's usually
when I come out I usually got the gun
you know massage myself a little bit and
then uh I pray before I walk out and
then um we usually all walk out together
we usually Pray Again like as a team and
then um I mean we run out and then um we
shoot after that um I stretch more a
little bit um then after that uh I think
that we're on the minute Mark when
everybody you know does the anthem
before the anthem I pray again before
and then um that's when we do the anthem
so that's really much it really much to
it but there's a lot of stuff I mean you
know you see the fans come to the game
just get ready for the game but so much
before I feel like I had no idea
obviously you know what went into it but
you starting from the morning up you
know you feel like you're doing
something every hour yeah you know to
get ready and um I think the biggest
thing the newest thing I saw was and
actually the coolest thing really was
going in the stadium before everyone
gets there and then you're I mean and I
don't know about you but like my case I
was the first couple first ones shooting
so yeah I'm in the empty gym and it's
the NBA arena and I think that was kind
of my first welcome to the league like
dang shoot the first welcome to the
league was I mean I'm starting to hit it
right now like that rookie wall where
it's like I mean your body starts start
wearing down you start traveling
everything I I mean like before when I
was like two or three I thought it was
just like all peaches and cream
everybody it just roll the balls out and
um like it doesn't you know take a lot
on your body but like I mean uh shoot
I'm definitely grateful you know to be
in this in this league for sure but yeah
no it's yeah obviously grilling season
but you know what we're playing 30 if
you're lucky in college compared to we
probably we would have been done already
so would have been done we still G no
it's crazy um but yeah no let's let's go
back to um Allstar um we're going to
name our five starters it can be if
they're if they're starters or not it
can be really anybody you want five
starters Allstar starters I'll start
with I mean I'll probably keep it one
the East let's go we can go back and
forth I'll do
I don't know
Tyrese all right so so I got one
um wait wait halberton or uh Maxi
halberton oh all right
then I
got I got
Brunson okay let's
go good donov
Mitchell all right I got we doing guards
anybody you want yeah I put yeah
um I'm not going to lie I put Brun in
there
okay all right let's
do oh if for East yeah Jason
Tatum
PG
Giannis ah dang I'll put and be dang all
right
dang might have to be dollar time put
Dame he's not going to be the five
obviously but damn couple
guards all right I got I got I got I
got I got um I got
yic it's good solid shees that's
Unstoppable lineup you're big for sure
that's a physical lineup right there
yeah no you'll get it you'll get it um D
I forgot about
Steph I mean you got Tyrese over step I
don't know I throw him somewhere in
there but actually where's Sabrina who
you think Three-Point Contest
um I got step Steph yeah cuz they're
both shooting from the same distance
though right they changed it yeah not
NBA I think she's still using the
women's Ball but yeah I still got staff
I gotta go with Steph I mean that's who
I grew up the greatest sh of all time
yeah you can't for sure for sure I would
be surprised though I would be surprised
yeah now before we wrap it up let's
do I don't know what you two or three
how many more questions some fans you
want I like these questions they're
pretty let's do some like uh not heavy
ones you know more like some fun ones
yeah some fun ones T there you good oh
this a fun one from Mrs shuttleworth who
is it was the team clown the team
clown ah like everybody pretty chill but
I would
say tar it it it'll be TI me yeah it'll
be TI me all right we're going to do one
more yeah I mean we talked a little bit
about the difference between college and
the NBA um I talked about kind of the
spacing of the floor for me but what was
like
the difference you can on and off the
court I mean from college to
NBA uh I would say the most that stuck
out to me was yeah like off the course
stuff where um like you're in college
you're doing work you're going to class
living a a student athlete life and then
you transition to like a like a career
um type of life I mean you can do yeah
you can do whatever whatever you want
like you know that's your job you go to
your job and come back home and go to
your job or do whatever you have to do
it's no school no like nothing no other
responsibility you have to worry about
for sure job that's definitely the
biggest change I guess but yeah know
you're lit going to practice I don't
know what time you guys practice but
we're probably finish around one and you
get the rest of the day to do whatever
you want like usually doing homework
going to another class yeah I mean my
college we they would meet us to our
classroom so like yeah they would meet
us our
classroom so like we we they had made
sure we had to you know go to class and
everything yeah that's tough that's
tough yeah well I mean that about wraps
it up I appreciate you coming on welcome
party um and I guess we'll see you
tomorrow at the game yes sir see you
tomorrow get this
[Music]
dub